I'm going to start it off with a puzzle, just, just to get us going.
So I've taken the ACEs, the Kings, the Queens and jacks out of a deck of cards.
So you can see I've arranged them in a four by four grid and the positives.
Can you arrange these cards so that every row,
every column and the two diagonals have a nice a
King,
a queen Jack in them and every
row column and the diagnose.
I also want them to include a club, a heart, a space,
and a diamond. It's like a Sudoku. It is like a Stokey.
So try it out is it should be the same kind of thing. As, as though CU uh,
there is a solution I'm not trying to catch you out. There are many solutions,
so try and find a solution. How many solutions can you find? My Rose? Okay.
Already working. I've got ACE King queen Jack in each row,
and I've got Cope's heart spit diamond in each row, but my columns, they work,
what do I need to do this ACE? Can't be in the same column as an ACE.
I don't want to put it there either.
I can't have hearts in the same column as heart.
What about if I just swap these two over this season, along with that, I don't,
Oh, I've got my Kings though, in the same column.
So maybe I can swap those two over. If I keep thinking about it,
I want my diagonals to be like this as well. I've got a club and a club.
Maybe I can swap the Jack and the queen, Ava, keep going like this.
So you keep trying this out, swapping them over, seeing what's works.
If you're like me,
you're probably going to find yourself getting into a stock place at some point
where it's just not working.
So what I recommend is you do treat it like a Sudoku, do it, pen and paper.
I think it works out better. So here's my Sudoku kind of version.
I know what the sort of thing I want. I want an eight, a King,
a queen, and a Jack in every row column diagonal.
I want club, heart spade,
diamond doing the same thing. And so then, yeah, let's just think it through,
let's do the ACEs and let's see where it fits on the next row.
So it can't be in the first column.
It can't be on the diagonal matching without ACE.
So it could be in the third or fourth box or for no reason,
let's put it in the third box. Let's see what happens when I do that.
If I do that, that does help.
I'm going to look at the fourth row because I can't do this first column.
I can't do that the third column. And I can't do the diagonal either.
So I can't be in that box at the end. So it has to be there,
which means I now know where the last ACE goes. It has to be on the third row,
fourth box. So it's nice and pleasing and essence though, kind of way.
And the suits are the same. And if I did clubs, it can't be the first column.
Can't be the diagonal.
It can't be here because I've already got ACE of clubs or ready,
which means it has to be in the last box on the row.
Where else could my clubs go? Well, if I look at the fourth row,
it's not the first column.
It's not the fourth column and it can't be ACE of clubs. Again, puts it there.
And then that forces the last club to go here, I think,
and you just carry on and not way,
here's one of the possible solutions you could do.
So the last row is going to be, we're gonna need the King.
We will need the ACE.
We will need the Jack I'm right there in the bottom queen of hearts.
And that should work every row, every column.
And the two diagonals as well has an ACE King queen and Jack,
and also one of each suit clubs, hearts, spades, and diamonds.
It's kind of like a Latin square. Latin squares are quite famous.
It's kind of like a double Latin gray, really Latin square.
I would have four objects and I want these four objects to appear
in each row. And each column, it doesn't have to be the diagonals, by the way,
I diagnosed this fun for a puzzle,
but it's not going to be what we're going to do for the maths.
If I just had them as a, B, C, and D,
I want ABC and D to be in every row and every column without
matching up. So I could have a, B, C,
D a, B, C, D a,
B, C, and D. That's a Latin square. Yeah.
What we're doing is kind of a double Latin square.
I could do another Latin square in the same boxes. I'll use the numbers one,
two, three, and four this time. So it looks different.
So we can start off with one, two, three, and four,
and then fill in the rest of them.
So it's a Latin square and I want each combination to appeal
once only. So if I do the rest of it, it would be one,
two, three, four, one, two, three,
four one two, three, four, like there.
So there's two Latin squares and they're kind of superimposed on top of each
other,
but every combination occurs once it's called a Greco
Latin square.
And it sounds like a pure mass thing has loads of applications and
real life maths.
And I was taught it in statistics and it doesn't sound like something you would
be taught in statistics,
but it something that you would use when you're designing experiments,
imagine your organizing some sort of tournament.
Um, what a ping pong tournament. Okay. You got the ping pong tournament.
Very exciting. It's a four day tournament, right? It's a big deal.
And you've got team letters and team numbers. If I use this.
So on the first team it's ABC and D on the second team, one, two,
three, and four.
And let's say your slots for playing games are ATM 10:00 AM.
And then there's a 2:00 PM slot and a 4:00 PM slot.
Isn't it bit unfair. If you have to play at 8:00 AM, first thing in the morning,
you might not be in playing at your best. So it would be fairer.
If every player got to play a game at 8:00 AM.
If every player got to play one of the slots,
then that would be a fair thing to do. And that's what's happened here.
It would also be fair. If every player a B, C,
D gets to compete against every player, one, two, three, four,
and that's what's happened.
You've arranged the tournament so that every player gets to play each opponent
and every player gets to play in each slot.
So everything's nice and fair, but also it allows you to make comparisons.
Let's say I wanted to compare player a player C I can compare them
because both players I've played in each slot and
both players have played all the other opponents.
So if you add up their total score, you can tell, which is the better player,
these, this idea for designing experiments.
So there aren't these little hidden biases,
so you can arrange your experiments so that those kinds of biases all spread
out and everyone has put in the same situation.
So then you can make comparisons between two different things.
So this works for a four by four square.
Does it work for other sizes? Okay. Two by two, three by three,
find it doesn't work for a two by two square. It's too small. Just doesn't work.
We have a, and B and well, let's put a B here.
I've relaxed the diagonal rule now. And we've got one and two now,
where am I going to put number one here?
I can't put it there because I've already done this.
And I can't put it here because it would be in the same column.
You'll find that you can't do it for two by two square, too small.
It's impossible. You can do it for a three by three.
So if you've got a prime number size,
a nice though rule is let's start with ABC.
Let's take the first Latin square and for each row,
I'm going to advance it one place across.
So now I'm going to start on the second square and there'll be a, B, C,
and then for the next row, a, B, C for my next Latin square, with one,
two and three, I'm going to advance them two steps across.
So for the next row, let's move it two steps along and have one,
two, and three. And then from the next row, let's go another two steps along.
So go one, two and three, and you say, Hey, that works.
So we've got this Greco Latin square. There's liberal,
Latin square for three by three. We do it for five by five as well.
Because he's a prime member.
So obviously the next question is a six by six. Does it work for six, five, six?
That's difficult. In fact,
so difficult that famous mathematician Euler
got involved. Uh, so it's,
it's got a special need because it's a special case. It has a special name.
They call it the 36 officer problem.
So you've got six regiments and each regimens has six officers
of different rank. And you want to arrange them into one of these squares.
So you've got different ranks and different regiments in rows and columns,
Euler near the end of his life. He thought I'm going to try this problem out.
He came up with loads of different methods for
designing these Greco, Latin squares,
all these different algorithms and methods for making them for constructing
them. And he made three by three, four by four or five by five,
seven by seven. He could make eight by eight, nine by nine.
Everything that he tried failed for six by six.
And he said, I don't think it can be done. I keep trying. It keeps failing.
I've not found a single solution. If there is a solution,
it's going to be some kind of crazy irregular pattern.
I don't think it can be done.
And I can't see a way of showing it without just checking every possibility.
So he said, well, two by two, can't be done.
Six by six. Can't be done. And for the same reason,
he decided 10 by 10 squares.
Can't be done 14 by 14 squares. Can't be done.
Odd numbers, fine. He could do the multiples of four. So four, eight,
and 12. And all of that, that's fine. You could do that.
But all the other even numbers he couldn't solve.
So he conjectured, I used to become a conjecture. They were impossible.
Can't be done. And it was a conjecture for a long time.
Well, it was proven in 1901,
a hundred years ago, French mathematician gust on Terry.
He proved it by checking every possibility,
which is 9,408 possibilities.
And he showed that the six by six grid is
impossible. It can't be done. Father was right. So when it was right,
the six by six is impossible. I don't want to be fair to gust on Terry.
He did have a general proof. He wants a proper mathematician.
He had a general proof, but he also checked every possibility, which is funnier.
How did.
He do it? Because he didn't have computers. Did he's manually do it.
And he manually did it exactly for the next question,
of course is 10 by 10 impossible. Now, wow.
That's going to be a lot of cases to check. You want to check those.
That was an open problem for a bit longer until someone proved that
they're impossible. The, the tens, the fourteens, the eighteens, the 20 twos,
they're impossible. They can't be done. That was proven in the 1920s.
The proof was wrong. The proof was wrong,
but it went unnoticed for 30 years until
1959, an Indian mathematician called Raj Bose,
who was working in the same kind of area. Look to the proof.
That's funny, funny, there's something wrong about that. And he went,
I'm going to try and construct one of these impossible grids I needed
mathematically. He could able construct a 22 by 20 cheaper.
So that was one of these that was meant to be impossible. So this huge grid,
double Latin square, and he could make it, which shows that yeah,
oil was wrong. That there was a 22 by 22 example,
and then working with other mathematicians. And also,
this was one of the early uses of computers.
We're talking about 1950s computers as well.
They could get a 10 by 10 example,
10 lots of to cut us up superimposed. It's a beautiful image.
I say they had examples where, where they could construct them.
Uh, oil was wrong. They could do a 10 by 10. They could do a 22 by 22.
They called them [inaudible] spoilers.
I think it's a kind of a joke is kind of a joke.
So they had these and then very quickly they could prove it in general,
10, 14, 1822, these ones that were meant to be impossible.
They were not impossible. They could prove it. They could be done.
Now we have a way to directly construct them as quite involved,
but we can actually create these supposedly impossible
grits. So that means only two and six is impossible to,
I'm not surprised by it's this small. It's just too small to work.
Six. I find surprising, especially cause three, four, five work,
six doesn't work.
It's this really kind of strange one odd one out,
and then all the other numbers work.
So the moral of the story is even a great mathematician.
One of history's great mathematicians, even someone like Euler can be wrong.
And of course never arranged a ping pong tournament. We have 16 members.
Thanks so much for watching this.
Some more footage from this interview on our extras channel called number file
two.
Two Latin squares on top of each other. Can we do three?
Here's a four by four as I add another Latin square to it.
So I'm going to use circles plus triangles.
And squares,
and a huge thank you to those of you who are able to support us on Patrion.
That support lets us add a few bells and whistles,
more animations and things like that.
Some of your names are on the screen at the moment that are playing a bit of
ping pong. And if you go to the number fire website,
you can see the full list of all our supporters. For more information,
there are links in the video description.